qui vota changé c'était mieux avant où
est passé le t1 les petites les meules
énorme je vais vous expliquer je vais
faire simple j'ai juste grandi j'ai
commencé les vidéos à 22 ans j'en ai 30
aujourd'hui vous comprendrez donc que si
je parle de petit homo les normes à
présent ça me donne un petit côté
pointer pas super copier vous savez je
suis casé maintenant adieu les des 10 me
les choses évoluent change mais je peux
vous rassurer c'est dans le bon sens et
je resterai un grand gamin toute ma vie
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est du courage qu'il faut avoir la
star ac et 30 balles tu rentabilise ont
fait pas demi-tour t'affronter peur tu
es là pour ça mec je vais pas te lâcher
je te jure tu vas le faire c'est normal
d'avoir peur je te demande pas de l'aveu
de pas avoir peur
là c'est la vie réelle mon avis elle va
te mettre des bâtons dans les roues et
là c'est justement faut affronter quand
on se met à terre tu te relèves stybar
ici city et yéti et resterez serait-ce
tu lâches pas tu lâches pas t'es pas un
mec qui lâche toi philippe abadie masi
vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y allez allez
allez allez allez allez
ouais mon pote je l'avais
[Musique]
ça
enfin c'est quoi ce rêve
je n'y crois que mr
je suis monté trop
amédro
pouvait se rêve
[Musique]
d'abord